thank you
[Music]
all right who here likes the movie
Shawshank Redemption I love it I've
never watched it it was a Shaw Shank
Redemption wait is that the jail one
yeah don't don't hurt me
okay do you know what happens
is about jail right no it's like jail
rights and [__] he's taking his hint
it's a musical he's like it's about
Redemption I thought it was about jail
like the jail was all corrupt and [__]
up right and then like they're like
they're feeding the garbage in here
outside of them I'm gonna watch it yeah
you should watch it you should watch
outside of those themes I'll give you a
very very high level just for the sake
of this conversation ultimately a guy
goes to jail and then he and Morgan
Freeman try to escape all right okay um
so oh I didn't know it was that one
wrote it down prisoners in real life
kind of have a very Shawshank Redemption
like breakout huh all right let me show
you this let me show you this photo
oh [__]
whoa whoa straight up hole hey for real
made a hole in the [__] brick wall
that's so cool honestly that's cool
but according to him he said that people
that try to break out of jail or laughed
at like lame-o well this kind of
happened well he speaks for everyone in
prison what do you do you like Splash
vinegar at the wall and make it soft or
something apparently they used an
adapted toothbrush in some way so
whether they like chiseled it down or
whatever and we're just kind of like
every day just yup dude in Shawshank
or is it Escape from Alcatraz they do a
similar thing and then they take like
what they um what they mined out of the
wall for the day and they walk in the
prison yard and they put holes in their
pockets and then just like Drop It On
The Ground yeah yeah so in Shawshank
again spoiler alert they're they're
literally taking a [__] they had to
cut out of like this mini pick-ass
hammer type thing that was in the Bible
and stuff so he'd hide his little hammer
in this Bible and they take it and every
night he would just [__] hack a
little bit at a time especially if it
was rainy or anything like that right
and then you could have a movie poster
or some chick from like back in the days
and they would just cover that hole so
anytime you like were to visit that
prison cell you would just see a move
post you wouldn't see the whole bag
that's why they don't let people have
posters they said anytime there would be
excess Rock and stuff you take that put
in his pocket and as he's walking around
midday we just drop it out of the side
of his pants taking a walk right she's
taking a walk it's really really cool
you got to see it spoiler alert all that
good stuff really cool now so these two
prisoners they use an adapted toothbrush
so they use a toothbrush and some sort
of metal object that like work together
and they found a design weakness and
exploited that in the construction
something that had to do with the rebars
shout out rebar guys right there right
there there's yeah
exploit a construction design weakness
in the prison to access untied rebars
between the walls and use those to
further their escape wow after that
these two guys named Garza Nemo then
scaled a high prison wall and were able
to escape isn't that [__] sick they
got out really sick because yeah because
it's more than just a hole they would
have to keep going there's like other
stuff however no they farted and they
got hurt they farted no that's a good
guess one more do you want one more yes
yeah one more please just one more try
one more
tell you what the cameras are I actually
know this one
it was like they're trying to pass by
the guards and then they went and then
they're like who's that that's not me
that's you oh [__] you know
I honestly can't go past guards dude
[Laughter]
so these two guys managed to actually
escape the jail but of course this game
short-lived because they decide to stop
for pancakes and are identified by
fellas they went to like IHOP right they
went to IHOP I mean if you're wearing
those striped jumpsuit stuff or the
bright orange one they couldn't wait
because it's like Oh Brother Where Art
Thou yeah you didn't hear about this one
ball and chain wow what happened why oh
no because because when we do host
duties I figure we all know about
everything yeah we're always seeing each
other's random yeah wait so they stopped
by to bypass they had money to buy
pancakes like that they're gonna die in
a ditch they probably got money in their
booty hole yeah probably that's amazing
just like a Shawshank spoiler alert you
know I mean you don't just Escape you
escape with a couple of things that you
may have acquired over time in order to
figure out how to maintain your like
escaped I almost want him to get away I
could see how the Temptation would be
too high though dude you've been in jail
so long and then you see pain and you're
like pancake and then like that's what
everyone says the food sucks and they
always dream of food do you think
they're just gonna die in ditch I'm sure
they have money you know like people in
jail have money randomly yeah you gotta
get to where it's safe first and then
you can eat wait someone recognized them
in the restaurant apparently in some way
but maybe not that them specifically but
maybe it was what they were wearing or
maybe you know just that's IHOP that's
closest to that Institute they're just
covered in dirt and mud and they look
like there was a nurse yeah yeah they
have barbed wire tattooed on there it
just straight up says like the facility
that they're coming from you know yeah
and then they're like how did you know
it was so cool black and white stripes
man the waitress was like I can
like DuckTales burglars or maybe the
waitresses like my husband's in jail I
know that jail yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know what I mean you never know
conjugal far away man
the two men were spotted by members of
the public at the IHOP on the early
hours of Tuesday morning so I mean this
is where the cops in the IHOP and
they're like looking around and then
they hear a fart
and then that gives them away that's
that's probably what it is that's
probably what happened people in the
diner don't usually fart you need
you're farting already
are you nervous
why are you farting boy you're drinking
milk
are you nerves there's always that same
trucker talking to mod yeah always
sexually harassing her hopefully yeah
hopefully watch come on back tonight
would be [__] them all might finally get
in give me give me mod just give up just
go on a date with me once I've watched
that in like so many different movies so
many yeah yeah and she's so Snappy she
says something about like I'd rather get
eaten by a gator live would you like
another refill on coffee and she just
one every day stop it Tommy Tommy and
like what is this guy's route that he's
there every day
like these truckers yeah it's like
shouldn't you never see these people
ever again is that why I deliver locally
I drove 18 wheeler locally
it's a big shipment 18 wheeler locally
we mostly just make noise in business
Parks we don't really do but we get paid
to make a lot of noise so keep a noise a
smoke
where was this what what area was this
in jail in uh this is in uh Shawshank
Ohio no no I'm just kidding this is
actually in a place uh in Virginia
uh Newport News jail Annex in Virginia
dude they were so close yeah prison
officials discovered that John Garza age
37 and Arlene Nimo age 40. if we want
them to get away I kind of do yeah
you're so close it's like and then we
find out they're [__] crazy murderers
I know
it's just Primal though because it's a
good store yeah yeah maybe that IHOP is
a plant so that you can get oh yeah
it's like the juiciest actually like FBI
operators yeah dude
[Laughter]
finally works
You overcooked my eggs again federal
funds boy you cut into the pancake and
there's a [__] microphone in there
have you seen in a in better call
assault Gus ring has a house that has a
fake family
as a cover oh really well I gotta see
that there's us was my face
villain like the way that was why he got
so much [__] screen time You Better
Call Saul the way he was the guy that
speaks Spanish yeah oh he was so good
yeah he's the Chicken Guy yeah
you're screaming cocaine there right but
I thought all the bad guys spoke Spanish
he was the guy with cancer who had a
wife right
no that's the main character I think no
oh he was the guy who says hey [__]
yeah he was yeah that's right it was the
guy with the kid that has cerebral palsy
yeah no he was the kid it was the kid
oh yeah so the reason you like Shawshank
is that it's not just about the Escape
it's about the plan after the Escape is
very very good oh
like they're gonna fulfill one of his
lifelong dreams or something it's like
this how they their plan kind of stopped
at a point but in Shawshank it's beyond
and it's very very clever yeah okay it's
a good movie it's one of the best movies
ever made it's [__] good it's my
father-in-law's favorite movie
I don't know Peter Jackson
in New Zealand uh the the [__] kid
from Breaking Bad
[Laughter]
uh horror [__] oh tons yeah and it's in
the same universe as it did because of
that oh Frank Darabont did yeah go who
did um Walking Dead as well you did the
first season yeah he was the showrunner
and they booted his ass so they could
make more money off of it
it's a really good movie that first
season was very good so very good which
one Walking Dead
Walking Dead yeah that yeah it got
really bad what happened Frank darma got
oh it was making it was a hit killer
killer killer hit right and then they
were supposed to pay him a certain
amount if he was on the show for a
certain amount of time at what time
around when do you think they kicked him
out
um I think he didn't last till season
two really okay because I liked it up
until the point where like the governor
came he was sick and they built him up
sick and they just [__] it all up
after that I agree with you they built
him up real good he was a great villain
I would have wanted I wanted to see a
war go and then like I just stopped
watching Once they killed Glenn I was
pretty much done with the show anyway
yeah did you start watching the Mexican
Walking Dead the California Walking Dead
I gave up I just love that world so I
gave it a chance
um but it's like the same format I think
they got used to a certain format so did
you just bring it up like that just to
tell me not to watch it
the best post-apocalyptic show of all
time is Last Man on Earth yes 100 that's
why I thought you know was off that's
why I thought you would get it because I
said it was a Shawshank Redemption to be
in this video you didn't even [__]
get it I know we're talking about it
I've never seen that she's never watched
it either last man on it it's such a
good show it's a good show but it's a
it's a TV sitcom where I think you have
to watch from the beginning it's not
something where you can watch one so
Will Forte is with like you know the
chick from madman like the the wife the
hot chick the blonde Hendrix big busty
chick Christina Hendricks no January
Jones oh thank you Junior James
Earl Jones you know Will Will Forte is
the last man on earth right he gets with
January Jones was like a Survivor and
she's like my favorite movie is
Shawshank Redemption and he's never seen
it so he's like me too he's like it was
a show
[Laughter]
that's a great joke such a good joke
yeah but he just tried to like get [__]
and he's a total loser he's a loser it's
so [__] funny oh my God
[Music]